if for some reason someone has actually
never seen anything you've done before
what is the first thing you want them
watching and why
oh my gosh i
[Laughter]
um that's so that's so difficult well
see this because um
it's a really fun movie uh
i think that they did such an amazing
job with it the flying sequences are so
exciting um
tom is extraordinary uh
miles is extraordinary all the pilots um
i don't know just because it's the movie
that's coming out and it's so much fun
uh you and tom are fantastic together
you have great chemistry was any sort of
did you do any sort of rehearsal is it
just because you guys are great actors
we had rehearsals um we
uh had time to more like you know not so
much running the scenes is um talking
about the characters talking about the
scenes talking about the script um
and uh
yeah it was
he's a delight and joy to work with he
makes it easy yeah he is the goat he
really is i i have nothing but positive
things to say about what he does
especially like in this movie um i heard
that he took a lot of people up in the
planes to um you know for the flight
stuff but because you weren't in any of
the plane sequences like that did he
take you flying or no well i am in the
plane in the film um i'm not talking
about spider jets i did not go in those
i did not go in any of those on any of
those flights no but uh it was exciting
enough what what i had to do with him um
i had never experienced anything like
that before yeah i don't i don't know
how he gets insurance to make these
movies i was asking myself the same
thing as i was in the plane as he
started the engine of the plane that we
were in and flames burst out of it and
we pulled that onto the tarmac and all
the producers were waving at us like
this as we were going
ready to take off i was thinking how do
they get the insurance for this um but
you know he's an excellent pilot um he's
excellent at so many things um and
piloting is one just one of them
a little bit of a fun question you just
joined what's called the instagram i
know
right
and i'm so curious what made you finally
take the plunge i don't know i i think
that like sometimes you know i came to
realization some things are inevitable
it's like
it just feels like
i don't know it felt like the right time
to do it and um
i was a bit of a dinosaur so i thought i
may as well join this join this century
when you think back on the shoot of
making top gun maverick what's like the
day or two that you're gonna remember
for the rest of your life the whole
thing every day was something that i had
never experienced before
the sailboats the
motorcycles the planes just the whole
scale of the film
um
working with tom who
is like no one i've ever met before um
all of it was um
all of it was special on that note i
gotta stop i'm just gonna say seriously
congrats on the movie it really is
so good i'm so glad you liked it thanks